シダーワーサという仏教で特別な梵天の次元決めてますね
それは上空天ですか？上境天ですか？上位天
上空天かな この上空天にはこの凡夫は生まれません
上空天というのは一来
普賢華の方々が生まれるところなんですね
弥勒も一来 もう全く得られない
無想というところに これはアサンニサット
それは第四禅定のある状態なんですね
まあそちらにはこの聖者が行かないんですね
まあ仏教の人にはやってはいけないという瞑想ですから
無想の瞑想はね 利川地っていうのは
まあ地獄の次元ですね
そちらも聖者が行かないんだと
残りのうちに聖者も非聖者も得られる
いわゆる人間の世界で聖者も非聖者もいるし
天国にも聖者も非聖者も得られるし
普通の梵天にも聖者も非聖者も得られるんです
聖者がいないところは
あの地獄の四つの地獄とこの無想というところなんですね
ですから 日本で人気のある仏様は誰ですか？あれ
あの阿字楼陀 ありえない
おじさんは強奪だから
まあ一応大乗仏教から見ればもう如来の化身だから
地獄にいるんですから
まあ地獄にないんです
聖者は誰も そういうのはただ人間のまあストーリーですね
人間ただ物語作るでしょ
これ イソップ物語みたいですから
好き勝手に物語作るだけ
そこは人間の欲望と普通の低次元的な考え方って心の波動はまあ綺麗に見えるんです
なんか感動的なストーリー作りたいし
まあそれまた綺麗なストーリー作りたいですから
阿字楼陀様が地獄に行ってそちらの人々を運んでくると
運び屋さんですね で その話を聞くとありがたくなっちゃうんですね
地獄の人もやっぱりお地蔵様があってて
運んでくる で 矛盾は感じないんですね
だからお地蔵様がいるならば
地獄にいる鬼たちをみんな運ぶでしょうに
そうすると地獄に誰もいなくなっちゃうんです
それから私たちが じゃあお前らは行くんじゃないかと言われるでしょうね
行っても大丈夫だと また運んでくれるから
ということになっちゃうんですね
そうすると永久的に地獄は無尽
無尽処地になっちゃうんですね
で まあよく だからまあそういう一般的な
この昔の人々がストーリー作るだけであって
ですから まあちょっとちょっと見たら
その人々のあのまあ小さい可愛い考え方自体は別に恐ろしい考え方じゃないんです
すごく可愛い小さい考え方なんです
子供たちに作ってあげるストーリーなんですね
それ以上別に尊い意味っていうのはないんです
じゃあ次に百三十二ページの
えーと 何ですかっけ パティサン
結章 朝日会館の講義では説明しましたけど
この この時間論ですか
この時間論 いくらか理解すればこの輪廻転生のことも理解できるんです
で 時間論というのは まあすごい大げさなことなんですけど
で あの この創造 創造することを信じている人々が
最初は何にもなかった
全く無の状態があって
その状態から神が全ては創造されました
それからは まあ創造したものはそれなりに変化して変わっていくんだと
わかりやすい人気の悪いストーリーで言えば
もともとはもう何もなかったところで
天 土地を作って それでまた人間二人だけ作ると
それで人間には増えることはできるんです
遺伝的に言えば早く死んじゃいますけど
同じ遺伝子だからね だから兄弟結婚しなくちゃね
三代目までは続けません
医学的に言えば死んじゃうんです
みんな まあそれはまあ科学はサタンの知恵だからね
それを置いといて まあそれで増え
増えましたと その理屈にあるのは
誰かが作らなかったらないんだよと
で そういう自分の身の回りのことを見てそう思っちゃうんです
植物見だっても何見だしてもなんかだから木がいて種が作らなきゃ次の木が出てこないんですね
人間がいて新しい生命作らなきゃ新しい生命は出てこないんです
だから自分には子供がいると
子供は自分が作ったんだから
だから作ったものがいて
新しいものは生まれるんだと
それで妄想しちゃうんですね
余計なところまで 妄想して
それだったら最初に誰かがいて
何か作ったんだ それからスタートするんだ
で オナービリックスはもうちょっと持っていけば
この最初にいる人がいわゆる神という概念ですね
それも誰かが作らなかったら成り立たないんですね
で 私にそういう創造論を教えた人々がすごい強い態度でしたからね
別に  で 作らなかったらありえないんだと
あんた方はもう何も誰も作らないで
もう自然に出てくると思ってるでしょ
それは間違いだと 見てみなさいと
全部作るんだからあり得るんだと
作る人が必要ですよ で
僕は逆に聞いたのは じゃあ誰かが作らなかったらないんですかと
ああ ないんですと 神を誰が作ったんですか？神は作る必要ないんだと
そういう あ それだったら神がいないんだと
当たり前でしょうと 作る人がなければ成り立たないならば
それで逆に いえ 神は作る必要はない
神は作る必要なくても神だけはいるんだ
それだったら我々も作る必要はないんだと
作る必要なくてもあり得るんだと
それで論理成り立たない
創造論っていうのは で
私たちは子供でしたから
私たち言う存分にね まあ向こうは認めませんですけど
まあ頭悪いんだからお前らにわからないんだと言って怒られて帰ったんだけど
僕はこの十歳 十二歳で作った理屈をいまだに使ってるんです
今でもチャレンジしてるんじゃあ出てこいと
全然あの まあそれぐらいのことでも
で 私たちいうのは やっぱり何がある
そのあるものから新しいものが出てきちゃうんですね
で 私たちは車を作ったと
車作るんだけど 車は新しく創造したわけじゃないんです
もともとあったものをいろいろ工夫して
いろんな法則によって組み立てて
車っていうものを作っちゃうんです
車作っちゃうんだけど
地球に一グラムの物質も増えたわけじゃないんです
人間何作っても そこで一トンのゴミを燃やしちゃうと
燃やしたら まあ例えば三百キロの灰が残ったと
じゃあ一トンを三百キロに減らしたんですかね？減らしてないんです
一トンは一トン そのまんまなんです
だから まあ人間の世界で言えば
我々いろいろ変化はするんだけど
一トンのゴミを強力な火で燃やしちゃって
これは五百キロにしましたと
自分で威張ってるだけであって
地球の一トンの物質量を全く減らしたことにはならないんです
で ある日面白く考えたのは
この まあ今春ですから
このもう秋になってくると
みんなこの植物やウーッと出ますから
全部切って もうかなり大量トラック来て
もうもう運ぶでしょ もう熱海なんか見ていると
もうあっちこっちもう庭で
もう全部枝切って切って切って
トラックに運んで運んで
すごい大量に運ぶんです
それは一年でできたものなんですね
一年以内に 俺は考えたのは
こんなことで地球の重さが増えるかなと
どうでしょうかね 植物はどんどんどんどん成長しちゃうと
やはり地球の重さが増えるんですかね
ね 例えば一グラムでもないでしょ？種っていうのは
一グラムの種を植えたところで
植えて五年待って待てば
どれぐらい大きな木が出るんでしょうかね
松の木とか すごい小さいでしょ
でもその木が出たらもう冗談じゃないんです
すごい重いでしょうね
あの重さがどこから出てくるんですかね
で あの  その場合でも もしかすると地球のあの質量が高くなるかもしれません
でも あのグラムの種が
トンの木になったとするならば
トン増えたわけじゃないんです
やっぱりそちらも地球からたくさんものをもらって大きくなっているんです
増える分は太陽のエネルギーなんですね
増えたとするならば 太陽のエネルギーもかなり重いものなんですね
だから で 太陽のエネルギーを計算できるならば
この分は物質が増えましたととは言えますが
そこで宇宙的に考えちゃうと
たとえ地球の重さが増えても
宇宙の重さはそのままなんですね
なぜならば 太陽が自分も自分が軽くなってるんだから
その一部が地球に来て
そこ一部が植物に入って重さが増えただけなんです
で 太陽から出すエネルギーもあの消えるんですから
宇宙から消えません ですから
新しくエネルギーが生まれることはないんです
増えることはないんです
物質の世界で ということで
この僕はこのある側面で仏教の時間論を喋ってますけど
で 何かものがあるということは
先に何かあったということなんです
先に何かなかったならば
今のものは出てこないんです
だからといって新しく何かできたわけでもないんです
ただ変えて変化して何かできただけ
一トンのゴミを燃やしたら
まあ半分以上空気に行っちゃうんです
空気に行って そこそこら辺でいろんなところにそれを広げて吸収されちゃうし
そこで灰というものはこっち側で残っちゃうし
ですからものは分解する
分解して必要な部分だけ組み合わせて新しいものが出てくる
新しい人間を作る場合も
やっぱり母親父親から細胞一つ一つないとスタートはしないんです
でも 母親から父親からもらうのはたった二つの細胞だけで
それで人間かというと全然そうじゃないんですね
それからご飯やらミルクやら鶏やら豚肉やら
そういうものから入れて入れて入れて大きな人間に作っちゃうんです
だから人間が増えても地球の重さが増えません
植物が増えると おそらくはっきりは私分かりませんだけど
エネルギーは増える可能性はあります
太陽のエネルギーを借りますからね
我々食べる植物食べて同じ太陽エネルギーは入れますけど
で 人間が あるいは動物はにはもうできないんです
質量 地球だけの質量を増えることは増やすことはできないんです
いくら人口増やしても
地球の質量はそのままです
人間消えちゃって植物だけになっちゃったら
まあもしかするといくらか増える可能性はあります
それでも植物も場所を取りますから
これ以上は増えませんよという状態になっちゃいますから
やっぱりそこに決まりが出たりしちゃうんですね
そういうことで 新しいものができるということが
もっとちょっと前に違うものがあったということ
で 全く同じものではない
想像を絶する違うものなんです
種と芽が比べたら全く違うでしょうね
種から芽が生まれたっていうことは間違いなんです
種も一つの原因になりました
種は 1MG だから 芽はもしかすると 5MG ぐらい重いでしょうね
その 4MG はどこから来たんですかね
ですから 我々は種から芽が出たと
卵からヒヨコが出たと簡単に考えてしまう
それは間違いなんです
卵からヒヨコが出ちゃうと思ったら
先にあったのは卵かヒヨコか
もう鶏かどっちかという問題が出てくるんだけど
それはもうそもそも考え方が間違ってるんです
種からも種から芽が出るわけじゃないんです
種も原因の一つで また他のものを物質も入れて芽が出る
また他の物質を入れて木になると
人間の場合も同じで 母親から父親からもらうのは二つだけの細胞で
それで人間できたんだということはあり得ないんですね
大量の物質を外から出して作るんです
そういう風に物事は変化していく
そういうことで 今ある現象がなぜあるかというと
もっと先にいろいろ現象があったんだからなんです
そこで考えてみちゃうと
じゃあもっと先にあった現象がなぜあったかというと
もっと先にものあったんだ
そういう風に考えちゃうと
初めはどうですか？っていう問題は出てこないんです
初めっていう言葉はバカバカしい
無意味だ 初めはありえない
この初め パーリ語でこのプッバコーティという専門用語を使ってたんです
プッバっていうのは first 初め最初ということで
コーティっていうのは end ですね
いわゆる先ということで
いわゆる最初のスタート
英語で言えば first origin
いわるここからこの時点
最初の時点 この時点で物事生まれたんだと
これ以前はなかったんだよというのはないんだと
ですからプッバコーティ first origin
この聖書にあるように
初め言葉ありとかね 初めに言葉あったならば
その以前何があったかというふうに聞きたくはならなくっちゃいけない
で  もうちょっと軽く考えましょう
だからこの今ある現象がもっと先にあった
いろんな現象があったんだから今これができたと
で 先にあった現象も もっと先のいろんな現象があったんだからできたんだと
それはまた先の現象があったんだからできたんだと
そうすると どこまで考えたっても
また先に現象が出てきちゃうんですね
ですから 過去は無限ということになっちゃうんです
正真正銘の無限 数学的に無限
だからものは消えますけど
なぜ消えるかというと
それ現象だから 消えるんだけど
他のものを作りちゃう
我々はご飯買ってきて食べたらご飯は消えますけど
他のものが生まれると思う
体の中にご飯入って あっちこっちちょっといじってみたらご飯つぶつぶ出るわけ全然ないんで
もう消えるんです 二度と現れないんです
完全に消える 消えるんだけど
ご飯とは全く関係ない違うものが現れちゃうんですね
だから五百グラムの鶏の肉を食べちゃったら
体に五百グラムの鶏の肉がつくわけでもないし
その代わりに五百グラムの人間の肉がつくわけでもないんです
いくらかの人間の体の細胞が成長するかもしれませんし
それで喋るは歩くは呼吸するは仕事をするは
そういうところにもそのエネルギーは消えていっちゃうんです
というわけで 五百グラム食べたんだからといって
五百グラム体が体重が増えることはないんです
みんな知ってるんだから
運動すれば体の体重が消えていっちゃいますから
運動で 体重ってのはちゃんと測って見られるものでしょうに
骨の重さやら血液の重さやら筋肉の重さやら
ちゃんとした物質的な重さでしょうに
それ運動すれば消えちゃうでしょう
体重減るでしょう ですから
この一時的な現象だから
まあ確実に消える 消えるんだけど
全く違うものが生まれるんですね
だから 例えば私もご飯食べたと
朝ごはん 皆さんは朝ごはん食べた
で 私が食べた朝ご飯は
こうやって教えることやら
いろんなことでエネルギーが消える
皆様が食べた朝ご飯のエネルギーは違う方向で消えちゃうと
みんなご飯食べたんだから
同じ同じところに消えたというわけにはまたないんです
それぞれの仕事が違いますから
そういうこと それで我々何を理解するかというとね
やっぱり何か現れたものが確実にある方向へ消える
人間っていうのは 例えばこの空き缶はこれからどうなるかというと
まあ大体わかりますね
それぐらいのことで全てまとめようと思っちゃうんですね
この空き缶はこれからはゴミ箱に行く
これからはリサイクルに行くとかね
じゃあリサイクルでまた空き缶になる
また缶になるんですかね
それわからないで何やってるかと
[笑い]だからじゃあこちらこの塗ってるあのペンキはどうなるんですか？それまた戻りますかね
同じペンキとして 戻らないんです
じゃあ消えますかと 消えることもない
それで 一つこの法則が見つかるはずなんです
今何かあるというならば
ちょっと前に何かあったということ
ちょっと前に何かあったっていう仮定するならば
もうちょっと前にまたあったんだ
また同じ法則でいえば無限だ
過去は いわゆる科学者いうこのエネルギーの不滅論のようなものなんですね
エネルギーは不滅だっていうのは
まあなんだか宗教的な言葉なんですけど
科学者の宗教的な言葉なんですけど
まあエネルギーはなんですけど
科学者は定義していないし
ですからまあそんなに特殊じゃないんだけど
ある変化しているものに全部エネルギーですよという一体一つの実体でとってるだけのことです
で まあとにかくものはそうやって変化していく
初めはなしと 初めという概念はありえないんだ
初めがあると思ったら
そこで自己矛盾で倒れちゃうんですね
なぜならば もし宇宙は虚空状態
何もない状態にいて いきなり始めたんだというならば
今ものがあるんだから我々いるんだというならば
我々の目の見回りでの突然何か現れる可能性はあるんです
宇宙の法則だから 初めがあったと宇宙に
誰か創造したんだと 初めがあったんだというならば
宇宙の法則だから 今も時たま今までなかったことは突然現れる可能性はあるんです
でも一度もそんな現象はないんです
新しいものが出てきちゃいますけど
それには過去があるんです
そういう論理で仏教ではこの FIRST ORIGIN
ブッバ・コティっていうものは NOT AVAILABLE
いわゆる出来上がら 成立しないんだと
なんかありませんとか
なんかそういうもう断言的な言葉を仏教で言いません
その場合もブッバ・コティっていうのはネッパンニャーアエティ
成立しません ということで言ってるんです
無限ですよと言わない
無限有限という概念は仏教でまた否定するんです
なぜならば 人には何か無限だと言えますかね
言えないんです すごいちみ細かいところにこう考え方が違っちゃうんです
あ これは無限だと言えません
どうやって無限だって知ってるんですか？知るはずもない
有限という概念 仏教はもう直言だと言ってるんです
いわゆる法則から見れば
どこまでも続くんだとということぐらいは言える
今の あるものは前にあったものが
前にものがあったんだから出たんだと
ということは 前にあったものからこれも出たんだというならば
そのやり方でやれば終わりがなく続くだろうという結論だけは出ます
だから無限だと言っちゃうと
そこでちょっと間違うんです
すごい厳密なんですね
言葉使うと 本当は無限なのに
その言葉は使わない 我々の普通の常識の無限という言葉で使えない
別にそんなややこしいこと言うのは無限だって言ってしまえば簡単じゃないかって
簡単じゃないんだ 無限と言うためには
その人は無限ということを認識しなくちゃいけないんですね
無限を認識することはもう不可能だから
例えば宇宙は制限ですよ
無限ですよと言っちゃうと
その言う人がそれより広い認識を持たなくちゃいけないんですね
自分が大きな認識で見たら
宇宙は小さいんだと言わなくちゃいけないんです
でも 宇宙は無限という人は宇宙の中にいるんだから
その人の心も 宇宙は無限だという人が宇宙の中にいるんだから
その人の心も無限なんですね
だから無限たる心を持って無限を理解するということはありえないんです
ですから 無限無限というのは使わない
それはもうあんた方の言葉の考え方のややかしいところですよということで
すごい丁寧に中道的な思考を発展させているんです
現代人にはあれは理解できないと思いますけど
あまりに難しすぎてね
現代人の考え方はすごい単純すぎるんですね
結局は じゃあ 今言ったのは物質の不滅論
で 心のこと考えてみましょう
我々には正真正銘の心というものがありますね
感情もあるし 認識という働きもあるし
単なる物体ではないんだから
この物体を動かしているエネルギーがあるんですね
それを心と呼ぶんですね
なんで今私に心がありますか？というともうちょっと前に心があったんだからなんです
同じこと 同じ法則なんです
なんで私は今生きてるんですかと
今生きてるんですか なんで今生きてるんですかというと
もうちょっと前も生きていたんだからなんです
一時間前死んでいたんだから
今生きてますよということはありえないんです
ですから 私に今の瞬間に心があるということは
このちょっと瞬間の前に心があったということ
でも違う心なんです 物質と同じ
ですから ある瞬間で私はすごく怒って
怒りの人間になっちゃう
怒り屋になっちゃう で
次の瞬間ですごくニコニコと笑っていて
笑っている人間になると
別々なんです 怒る時の私という私と
すっごくニコニコ笑っている私は違うでしょ
その時喋る言葉も違うし
アプローチも違うし 人間に対するやっていることも違うし
怒っている時はまた違う
ですから 瞬時に死んで新しい人が生まれちゃうんです
だから心は瞬間瞬間死んじゃうんだけど
消えちゃいますけど 消えるんだけど
新しい心が生まれるわけです
なぜ新しい心が生まれたかというと
前に心があったんだからなんです
何もないところに心が生まれるということはありえないんです
それだったら急にあちこち生命が誕生するはずでしょうに
そうでもないんです それで心も同じく
もう今心が 今の瞬間の心があるということは
前の瞬間に心があるということになると
またブッバ・コーティという最初の初期の時点というものはないんだと
成り立たない そこでちょっと考えましょう
おなかの中に生命誕生するでしょ
突然そこに心が現れますか
現れるはずがないんです
今までなかったんだと
おなかの中に生命は なかったものを新しく現れたんだということはありえない
法則から見れば そこに新しく生命誕生したならば
なんかもうちょっと瞬間の前に何かなければいけませんね
いわゆる前に何かなければ
今のものは出てこないんです
それはもう我々が言っているのも当然なんです
論理的に言えばそういうことなんです
そこでここで私が死んじゃうんだと
死ぬとその体には心が消えちゃうんですね
死んだっていうことは
物体は残して機械は残して機能は消えると
機能は業務的に全く消えるってことはあり得ません
そんなものはものは消えませんから
なんとかになるんです
ゴミは消える 消すことはできませんだからね
マジシャンなんかいろいろ物を消して見せるでしょう
本当は消すんですかね
消すんだったらすごいマジックなんですけど
それはマジックだけなんです
ただ人に見えないようにする
ただそれだけ ということで
まあ我々が死ぬということは
この体っていうのはずっと変化している
ずっと死んでいるんだけど
それは気にしない 瞬間瞬間心が死んで新しい心が生まれるんだけど
それも気にしない ただ
この長い間 この繋げている
この川のように流れている
このシステムを大きくまとめてみて
ああ 人が死んだんだと
その人はどこに生まれたんだと考えますけど
そういう風に考えてても理解できませんだからね
いわゆる八十年間のシステムを見て
次にどこに生まれたかといって
そこでまた八十年間のシステムと見なくちゃいけないんだから
瞬間瞬間に見えると そこはすぐわかるんです
瞬間だけ見るとどうなったかと見えるでしょ
例えばゴミを燃やしちゃうと
燃やす瞬間だけ見ると
ゴミがどうなるか見えるんですね
ゴミが炎になって煙になって
また灰になって そういう風になっていくことは見える
そうなるためにも 外から物質をまたいただくんです
それは簡単にわかるでしょう
燃やす紙がどのように生まれ変わりますか
生まれ変わる時は新しい物質をいただくんです
酸素とか でもって灰になるし
一部はもう二酸化炭素になったりして
そうやって違う方向へ行っちゃうし
これ一年後でどうなるかを探しても
それは見つからないでしょうに
私たちが知っている人間っていうのは生まれてからですよね
まあ十ヶ月とかもう経ってるんです
そこは紙が燃やす瞬間で紙どうなるんですか？とはまるっきり見えているのに
紙が燃やしてもう一日経つと
たったところで その紙はどこに生まれ変わったかと探したって見つかるわけじゃないんです
そこでまた変化して変化していってるんだから
見つかってももう確認できない
ということで 一般の人々には転滅転生っていうのは
じゃあ見つかりますよと
見つかるわけじゃないんです
見つかるわけないんだけど
転滅転生っていうのは
確実にこの法則的に厳密に絞ってみると
もう何のことなく当たり前の常識なんです
万べきな瞬間絞ってみろ
見たらまあまあ常識になってしまったんだ
となれば今のここじゃ
ちょっと前の心がなければないんだから
だから創造者もなしに
仏教で実体もなしに 輪廻転生のことちゃんと言ってるんです
実体があるならば そんな難しくはないんだけどね
物には実体ないんですよ
あてちゃんはこれからどうなると
あれ実体じゃないんだから
どうなるかわかったもんじゃないんだから
それぞれ違う物質をいただいて
違う形になっちゃうんです
ですから 私は過去世で全く違う人間でいたんだけど
この世の中に来た途端
この地球からいろいろ物質をいただいて
人間という形になっただけです
ここで死んで もし他の宇宙で他のところに生まれちゃったら
そちらの物質で違う生命に出来上がっちゃうんです
でもそれをスタートするためには
こちらで何かなければいけない
ということで心も消えません
心エネルギーだから ということになっちゃう
そしたらある人にまた僕言ったんだけど
この輪廻転生説明してて
僕が簡単に言ったのは
あんたに今心があるでしょ？あります
なんで今心がありますか？なんで今生きてるんですか？知ってます
わからない それであんたちょっと前に生きていたんだからです
それぐらいわかりますでしょう
それはもう当たり前でしょう
ということは 生きているということは心に入れたことにされる
なぜあんたに今心がありますか？と
ちょっと前に心があったんだから
それわかるのはわかります
そこで法則見つかりました
見つからない じゃあ教えてあげます
今これあるのはちょっと先に何かあったんだからですと
それが形の方です ですから
あんたがなんでこの世の中で生まれたんですよ？と言ったら
ちょっと先に行ったんだから
と言ったら ずばりそれで言ったのは
この今の 今なぜ心があるかということは
もっと前に心があるということですと言ったところ
そう言っちゃうともう終わりじゃないでしょうと
ずっと心があることになるんだと
なんかすごいことを言うんだ
そうですよと それは仏教で平気で輪廻言ってるんだから
僕で何のことなく輪廻言ってるのそれですよと
でもあまりも単純に納得させるんだから
また面白くないんです
[笑い] これすごい知恵が何のことなく
ちっともう ほんのちょっとのことで
知識的にインテリ的に教えたんだけど
それまた面白くない じゃあ信じない
[笑い] で まあしょうがないんですけど
まあとにかく輪廻っていうのはそんなもんなんです
すごい簡単に理解できるもんなんです
ちょっと法則だけ見つかれば
だから我々この なんとなく尊い宗教
神秘 不可思議なもの そういうの付加らない
この固定概念捨てないんだから
すごい厳密に科学者にならなくちゃいけないんです
もういい加減な合理的だねえなんて
いい加減な具体性 そういうの科学者が探してる
そういう物的証拠とかね
そんないい加減なものじゃなくて
厳密に絞って絞って瞬間に絞ってみると
もうわかるもんなんです
だから ヴィパッサナー瞑想ではすべての疑いは消えちゃうということは
ヴィパッサナー瞑想では人の体験っていうのは瞬間の体験に絞ってもらうんです
その瞬間で自我も消えちゃうし
私がいるという概念も消えちゃうし
私がいるとか 何私ってだというんですかと
ただいろんなもの流れてるだけでしょうに
この体だってもいろんな鶏の肉がここに入って流れていっちゃうし
ご飯が入って流れてると
どこに私がいるんですか
私の体のエネルギーは今減るでしょ
食べると そうするとこれも私でしょうか
私を一部もう消すってるんです
全然そんなこと気にしないで
私がどこに生まれ変わりますか？とよく聞くんですから
質問自体がバカバカらしいんです
だからもうあんたどこに生まれませんよと言いたいんだけど
そうするとまた誤解しちゃうんですね
ああ そうか だからもう答えられないで先延ばしは方法ない
答えはだからこそしっかりとあるんです
今の瞬間だけ見ろと ここにすべてがあるんだと
今の瞬間は次の瞬間からできたものなんです
で 前の瞬間と今の瞬間が同一ものかというと
そうじゃないんです じゃあ全く違うものかというと
そうでもないんです だから上と下
同一ものですか？全く違うものでしょう
じゃあ全く違うかというとそうでもないでしょうに
その瞬間の変化見えちゃったら
まあ私だっていう概念も消えちゃって
まあもう全部まあバカバカしい
自分は単なる無明だけで幻覚だけでやっていたんではないかと
今まで考えた知識も 今までやったすべての知識やらああだこうだ
全部もう あれ全部幻覚やと
というすごいぼーっとする瞬間というのを我々ブッダと言うんです
これすごい知恵なんです
体験だから わかったぞと
まあこれから悩む必要なんもないんだと
[背景音楽]